Dennis lehane author of more than a
dozen novels many of which have been
turned into hit films now Lane is out
with the book he says maybe his swan
song small mercies it takes place like
almost all of lahaine's work in Boston
during a seminal moment for the city
only real people come from New York
Austin Philly that area is that changed
yeah
yes I've broadened my horizons even
though California is now home Dennis
lehane continues to be defined by Boston
One Moment in particular the time his
father took a wrong turn and the family
wound up in the middle of a riot
[Applause]
was flabbergasted I still am
flabbergasted I remember just kind of
buffing our way through this massive
crowd people screaming it was medieval
one it changed everything in some ways I
always feel like childhood kinda ended
there for me in a lot of ways the
desegregation of Boston Schools began in
1974. I wouldn't care if they would
green a purple with the idea of putting
my kid on a bus when I have a school
right across the street and where they
should go black students were ordered to
be bussed to White neighborhoods and
vice versa leading to widespread
violence
it was throwing glass at black peoples
and little kids lahaine's new book small
mercies tells the story of a mom named
Mary Pat fennessy whose daughter goes
missing amidst all that Mary Pat is a
product of
um growing up in a housing project she
is a
chain smoking foul mouth alcoholic
racist single mom she's all those things
and yet you find yourself rooting for
her yes because she's trying not to be
at the very least she's trying now she's
open to the possibility that her entire
life has been built on a lie lehane
started publishing in the 1990s but his
name wasn't on most Radars until Clint
Eastwood turned Mystic River into a
movie in 2003.
I lost Mr Boyle how did you get the
blood in your car
my blood let's start with the front seat
that was followed by more like Martin
scorsese's Shutter Island I didn't
believe a crazy guy that's the beauty of
it isn't it crazy people they're the
perfect subjects they talk nobody
listens and two directed by Ben Affleck
including Gone Baby Gone why is this so
hard the cops don't want me to come in
here Lionel don't want me coming in now
you don't want the job no it's not that
we don't want the job we consult
privately before we make decisions like
these we do so many of your books I mean
an uncommon amount you know kid made
into movies is that always the plan for
you no I never thought I didn't want to
saw Mystic River that was only because
Clint Eastwood wooed me and wore me down
and nothing but like being rude like I
know it's pretty cool it was pretty cool
Clint will will say whatever you say to
him he'll say uh I'll say look it's not
for sale he'd say oh I know that I know
that but if it were
he just keeps wearing you down and
wearing you down so what was the
Scorsese cell
Scorsese
I mean fair enough how'd you get in it's
not visiting day
the fellows here the game and get bass
lately lahaine has transitioned to
television developing the show Blackbird
before signing a longer deal with Apple
TV this is the workshop is where we work
so writer's room so you come up you
storyboard it and then he's like all
right you're writing this episode you're
writing this episode and then they turn
them into me and then usually I give
them notes and they write again
and then they turn it back into me and
I'll give them one last round of notes
and then I take it over that's kind of
how it works and how much you change it
not too much I not I got good writers so
uh normally it's it goes through a tone
filter like on the tone filter it should
all sound
similar in tone let's just do Freddie
from you know top to bottom see where
these scenes go see where there's
opportunities before his next TV show is
out however lahain is eager to talk
about small mercies it's basically the
division in the city between
people who were
authentically racist and didn't want
African-Americans in their community
people who are authentically saying hey
wait a second we had no voice in this
you're telling us we gotta bus our kids
to another you know section of the city
and we have no say in that and we've got
90 days to figure it out
there was a legitimate side to the
argument than there was obviously a very
racist side to the argument Boston
Schools are more segregated today than
they were when the busing hap started
yeah what went wrong
I think so many things went look I'm 100
for desegregation of the schools it had
to happen as an argument in the book
where a woman says very clearly
something had to happen it had to but
busing itself was not a good idea it
didn't work
the proof is in the pudding there are
moments in this book where this horrible
painstaking stuff is taking place and
yet I marked it then there's these
moments of humor yeah that are like
this doesn't belong here but it does but
it does it does it absolutely does you
know and that I've been out in the world
I've met a lot of people I've never met
anybody half as funny as half of the
people I knew growing up in Boston
it's just it's a funny place and but the
humor is all steeped in this idea that
you're the butt of God's joke
you know The House Always Wins but every
now and then
we can you break their antenna yeah you
see their cat you know like something
you
know you steal this sister like
something's gonna happen you know that's
As Good As It Gets I will never send
another book outside Boston again if I
ever write another book it will be in
Boston why because I did it once and it
didn't feel right
if small mercies is his swan song novel
it comes in typical Dennis lehane
fashion
heartbreaking
yet completely unsentimental does part
of it make you a little reflective and
and sad though
if there's another book I'll do it I'll
be happy to do it no if I was literally
walking off into the sunset like I'm
done I'm going to go play golf you know
what I mean I'm not doing that I don't
believe in any of that I don't believe
in retirements I don't believe in
anything I just happen to be now in a
job that allows me to be creative that
allows me to tell stories most
importantly allows me to be around other
people I was really tired of the
lifestyle
I like that and that's that big
difference between you know sitting in
an office by yourself all day long
writing a novel versus being able to
collaborate you know he seems so much
brighter than his work I mean his work
is dark it is very dark and so it's so
nice to see that you know he is light
you know he said that to us too I mean
he because he he's after you know he's a
fun guy to talk to very Charming but his
work can is is it's tough I mean there's
there's not a lot of Happy Endings in
Dennis lehane books it's it's really
remarkable
's work that he has had and will
continue to do yeah it was a great
conversation yeah
hahaha